are you sure it's here we called Gotham
PD he hasn't been seen for over a year
what was that
disappeared they said they thought he
might be dead why come here
why Detroit the weather where's Batman
hey little birdies alone
let's just hope the helis passing
through
I'm detective Dick Grayson you want to
talk about what happened can you help me
Rachel that's what she calls there is
something inside of me nothing Bad's
gonna happen you don't worry take care
of a kid is complicated you know that
better than anyone I know how healing it
must be doing what Bruce did for you and
you lost your parents what happened
between you and Bruce guess we had
different ideas of how to do the job
[Music]
we're gonna go see some old friends tada
call me what do you want from me I've
been looking for you there are people
out there trying to hurt you
I feel danger there you are dear
what are you doing we all must make
sacrifices child
[Music]
just ever go away what the feeling you
got left behind
hey everybody is Charlie we got new
Titans footage and confirmation that
it's coming to Netflix so I'll explain
what's going on with the international
release because this is important for
how they're gonna release Young Justice
swampthing the Doom Patrol TV show any
other show that they make for the DC
streaming service I'm still doing that
giveaway for the streaming service all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll talk about the Netflix
release stuff first then I'll talk about
the footage because everybody just wants
to know how to get episodes like how
much do I have to pay for this extra do
service so here's the thing the DC
streaming service where these episodes
are coming is only for the United States
everywhere outside the United States the
episodes are going to Netflix so if
there's Netflix in your country there's
a 99% chance that you'll get episodes
the same day is everyone else everywhere
else so here's why that's awesome
one because you don't have to pay twice
if you live outside the United States
and you already have Netflix there'll be
weekly episodes starting October 12th
they didn't say exactly which day
episodes will be coming to those Netflix
territories but it's a lot like
Riverdale so if you watch Riverdale and
you're in the UK usually you get
episodes almost exactly when people in
the United States get new Riverdale
episodes they did the exact same thing
with Black Lightning so in the United
States outside the United States you
should be able to get episodes around
the same time no worries about that the
reason why they probably didn't tell us
about this sooner is is because Netflix
just finally signed the deal like they
were probably going back and forth
because these are millions and millions
of dollars for streaming rights so it
takes a while to negotiate that stuff so
why am 99% certain that they're gonna do
the exact same thing with Young Justice
in January when those episodes start
dropping then with the Doom Patrol TV
show the swampthing show every other
show that comes to the DC streaming
service so breathe a sigh of relief if
you were worried about having basic
access to the show forget about whether
or not it was good or bad or really
awesome just being able to get episodes
is the most important thing the other
really good thing about Netflix
co-financing a lot of these shows is it
means they
can pump extra money into them they'll
be higher quality that's why black
lightning and Riverdale look a little
bit better than some of the other CW
shows because they get a lot of extra
money that they can pump into the budget
from Netflix from these licensing deals
so it's actually a really really good
thing that this happened but I think we
all kind of predicted it now it's
officially confirmed world premiere is
happening this week at Comic Con I'll be
able to post my non-spoilery review of
the first couple of episodes on
Wednesday so we'll just remind people
about that when we get a little bit
closer but breaking down the actual
trailer itself you get a whole bunch of
new footage this is like their Netflix
trailer like hello we're coming to
Netflix you're gonna be able to get
episodes no matter where you live in the
world the scene in the Detroit Police
Department the police chief is talking
about robbing he's been inactive for the
past year there just to let you know
that he left Batman a year ago he's been
a police detective in Detroit ever since
then just like Chuck Dixon era Nightwing
the show actually moves to a bunch of
different cities so you're not stuck in
Detroit the whole time they actually go
all over the place including Gotham City
Hawk and Dove live in Washington DC so
they go visit them during an episode so
they go all over the place most of the
rest of the footage with a few
exceptions is from the first couple of
episodes so like this with Raven here
this is from the first episode she
doesn't know anything about her mother
or Trigon or brother blood the Church of
blood people just start coming after her
for mysterious reasons and she knows
that she has special abilities but she
doesn't totally understand it she just
knows that she has a darkness within her
that's like that my hero academia scene
where they all show each other their
quirks this is dove she's pretty
balanced level-headed she used to have a
relationship with Robin when he was
still with Batman she's with hawk right
now most of you understand that comic
book relationship where she's like the
aspect of peace he's the aspect of war
they're just normal vigilantes with
special suits that have special weapons
so like the feathers of her cape they're
they're actually serrated blades that
can slice people up really good Hawk is
a lot like Stephen amell's Oliver just
really really hardcore imagine a stabby
er crazier version of Oliver Queen circa
arrow season one when he was still
dropping all kinds of bodies you get
more scenes of the team coming together
a lot of this is just cut up from the
first three or four episodes you get a
little more of their origins and you get
this separate really creepy group
the redhead here coming after Raven
they're like a creepy random group
that's associated with the Church of
blood but it takes a little while before
you actually figure out who these people
that are coming for Raven are you just
see an escalating series of weirdos come
for her and try to take her you just see
it get worse and worse and worse until
you get more and more powerful people I
think they're just building up towards a
brother blood reveal towards the end of
the season you get a little bit more
that Raven power scene that they
released a while ago I've already done a
video about that where she just
manifests her powers she's locked up in
this church down in the basement they
kind of understand who she is and
they're trying to help her but they
don't know how to contain her so they're
just gonna lock her up and throw away
the key obviously she gets out like you
see her break out because there's a
smoke monster blowing up the side of the
building here so you see all these birds
flying things just get worse and worse
and worse and it's all about this
prophecy that they're building towards
all about Trigon trying to enter our
world through her so separately like I
said in my last big video you see
Starfire who even though she's had some
memory loss recently has been on the
hunt for Raven trying to track down this
prophecy that she's been following Dick
Grayson only learns about it in the
first episode so he's relatively new to
the case but because he is who he is he
tries to help her out my non-spoilery
review will be posting later this week
and then obviously when episodes start
dropping we'll figure out how we do
videos for that but don't forget that
the flash is also back not this week but
next week and then the DC TV shows on
the CW also come back around that same
time too so I will say I definitely wish
that they had done this trailer first
it's much better than the trailers that
they drop previously and I wish they had
talked about their Netflix plans but
like I said they probably had to wait
till Netflix pony DUP all those millions
and millions of dollars but everybody
breathe a sigh of relief while you wait
for everything click here for that brand
new spider-man far from home Mysterio
scene and click here to learn all about
this year's flash arrow three-way
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight